藥物研發，你想到什麼？應該就是很多穿白袍的人，在實驗室裡忙進忙出，然後花個幾十年跟幾億美金，對吧？
嗯，差不多是這樣。高門檻、燒錢、時間又長，而且還不一定會成功。
對，所以今天這個案例，真的讓我感覺「原來還可以這樣玩」。它是一家虛擬生技公司，沒有實體實驗室，也沒有上百個科學家，它用了三萬七千個 AI 代理，加速藥物研發。
等等，三萬七千個 AI 代理？這聽起來很像科幻小說的劇情。具體怎麼做的？這些 AI 真的能取代實驗室裡的工作嗎？
它其實不是完全取代，而是把很多前期需要大量資料分析、判斷的工作交給 AI。史丹佛大學的研究團隊設計了這個系統，他們稱它為「虛擬生技公司」。
裡面有一個虛擬的「首席科學官」，負責分配任務給底下的「科學家」AI 代理。這些代理分成四個部門，有的找藥物靶點，有的評估安全風險，有的決定藥物傳輸方式，還有分析臨床試驗數據。
所以它把整個藥物研發的流程，拆解成很多小的環節，然後讓不同的 AI 代理去執行，就像一個超大型的虛擬專案團隊？
差不多是這個意思。他們還把 Open Targets 這個巨大的公開臨床試驗資料庫接進去。有個很有趣的測試，他們讓這個系統去分析一個現有研究，想找出什麼樣的藥物在試驗中比較容易成功。
這聽起來很有意思。那 AI 代理真的有辦法找到突破嗎？還是只是整理現有資訊？
AI 代理先發現，Open Targets 裡很多試驗數據，並沒有清楚記錄藥物到底有沒有效。所以虛擬 CSO 就派了三萬七千多個代理，每個代理負責一個二期或三期臨床試驗。
三萬七千多個試驗數據，每個派一個 AI 代理？這規模也太大了。人類團隊要處理起來，恐怕得花幾個月甚至幾年吧。
沒錯，原文提到，這些 AI 代理只花了大概六小時，就把這些試驗結果都爬梳完，去找到試驗註冊、發表論文、新聞稿等各種資料。
六小時！這速度真的讓我很詫異。不過，光靠這些數據分析，真的能找出新的藥物策略？
它們不只整理數據，還建立了一套評分系統。這個系統發現，如果藥物針對的是在少量細胞類型中、像開關一樣作用的基因，那這種藥物成功上市的機率會提高 48%，進入二期試驗的機率提高 40%，而且副作用還會減少 32%。
這個數字很具體，也很有說服力。等於是 AI 幫忙找到了成功率比較高的「藥物靶點篩選」模式？
對，而且他們還讓系統更進一步，去評估一個跟肺癌相關的蛋白質 B7-H3。AI 代理發現這個蛋白質在腫瘤附近的結締組織細胞裡很常見。
喔，所以 AI 甚至能推測出這種蛋白質在人體裡面的作用機制嗎？
它們發現這些細胞會抑制附近免疫細胞的活性，讓身體沒辦法偵測到腫瘤。結果這個虛擬生技公司就提出了一個治療方案：用抗體標記 B7-H3 的細胞，再把毒性化療藥物導向這些細胞。
這完全是從零到一的創新提議了。而且最後呢？這個想法有沒有被實際驗證？
讓人驚訝的是，這套虛擬生技公司提出這個方案的時候，只用了 2025 年 1 月之前的數據。結果在同年八月，一家大型藥廠也獨立發現了同樣的策略，他們針對 B7-H3 的療法甚至還獲得了美國 FDA 的突破性療法認定。
等等，這就厲害了。等於 AI 代理提前預測了一個真實藥廠的重大發現，還沒花實體實驗室的錢，這成本效益也太高了。
這也是為什麼我覺得這個案例給台灣中小企業很有啟發。你看，藥物研發門檻多高？燒錢多兇？但這家公司，透過「虛擬化」和「蜂群式」的 AI 代理，卻能做出這樣的成果。
對，它沒有實體實驗室，沒有那麼多昂貴的設備，光靠資料和算力，就能在這麼高門檻的產業裡找到機會。
如果我是做顧問業的，我會想，我的團隊是不是也可以用類似的概念，讓不同的 AI 代理去扮演不同顧問的角色，幫客戶分析市場、擬定策略，然後快速產出報告？
或者是做服務業的，比如客服中心，讓 AI 代理去分析大量的客戶對話紀錄，找出潛在的問題模式，甚至預測客戶需求。這就不是單純的聊天機器人，而是能深度分析並給出建議的「虛擬顧問團」。
對一般上班族來說，我覺得可以學到的是，在面對複雜問題的時候，是不是也可以把問題拆解，然後去找不同的 AI 工具來幫忙處理。不用一個人硬扛所有事情。
讓 AI 成為你的「虛擬團隊成員」，把你工作中需要大量資訊處理、分析判斷的部分交給它們。這不只是提高效率，可能還能幫你找到人類想不到的突破口。
尤其在數據分析或決策情境，如果我們的資源有限，但又需要快速反應，這樣的「虛擬團隊」模式好像也提醒了我們，未來的工作型態可能會有很大的轉變。